make sure you shore up that blank black
falcon there is no black falcon i'm
green falcon there ain't a lot of
brothers out here man in space
[Music]
there no what
oh
snap yo
let no yo leonardo callarisian oh hi
yeah that's me
new
landlord
yo
yo you straight up running cloud city
right now dawg that's you man you out
there
swoosh well you know i i do my best z
man z powder big fan big fan well it's
real nice to make your acquaintance
straight up though i straight up man you
an inspiration to all of us man
you know the reason i'm out here in
cloud city dog man i ain't joking man
but your ideally though yeah ideally on
an ideal situation i would be doing like
what you doing i'll be up there like in
the high chambers of cloud city dog well
see if it's nice to meet you y'all right
on man cause they got me in the
carbonite room right now son that's
[ __ ] right they gotta be working
with some pig dudes and whatnot y'all
ain't no pig you know and you ever
noticed man there ain't a lot of
brothers out here man in space right
it's like they're trying to keep us down
man you know i i don't think that it's
the policy i just think it's really
really difficult to get to this level
you've got to understand the politics of
the empire
and at the same time all the motivations
of the rebels
all that all that all that all that but
ideally though man ideally what i'm
talking about is like me and you we
should like do something together though
man because if you think about it yo
when i was younger man i used to fly
those land speeders all the time my
friends was like man you should be
piling in one of the x-wings right and
so that's like disappointing man because
i got here and they just had me like
cleaning up the r2 units after the
x-wings come in see thief i gotta go you
should probably um man i'm saying man
how do we contact one another cause
that's the most important thing that we
contact one another yo look man ideally
though ideally though i would get to fly
somehow like the millennium falcon like
that would be cool and yo let me get you
my like my con i got my card in here
somewhere
man i'm just trying to find this pocket
right here
well you know what zeef
just give your information to lobot here
and
we'll be in touch nobody
man i see how it is i gotta talk to your
mandroid right now man
you
little white ass hair why you wearing a
cake though huh where you going the ice
planet hog
outrageous
[Music]
yellow falcon what do your senses tell
you destructo is a killing machine
his armor is impervious to our blusters
you got any ideas red falcon sure do
yellow falcon blue falcon you remember
our battle at dango bluff i'll take the
legs you take the blasters it was beaver
creek and i took the legs make sure you
shore up that flank black falcon
um
are you talking to me because
i'm the green falcon
no time for that black pelican purple
falcon arm missiles roger that farming
missile now
uh battle formations we're going in hey
roger's good hold up copy that frankie
my falcon
is green hey hey hey we can talk about
our falcon colors when we get back to
base black falcon right now we got a
mission to do fall into falcon formation
well here's the issue is that you're
gonna give me an order i'm not gonna
know you're talking to me
cause
i'm not in the black falcon come on
chill it out black falcon yeah black
falcon relax first of all i don't like
the way you guys are saying black second
of all there is no black falcon i'm
green falcon black falcon homie no one's
trying to get up in your grill here
uh-uh uh-uh uh-uh don't talk to me like
that no don't say grill like that
i'm the green
falcon
and i'm stopping so black falcon about
it what the [ __ ] do you mean by that
black falcon brother i understand what
you're going through do you no i don't
think you do
how would you feel if i called you red
falcon huh whoa
and purple falcon how would you feel if
i called you yellow falcon huh that's a
racist that was racist yeah that's
racist oh that is racist that's racist
oh see okay nope forget it black falcon
out green falcon
green falcon dammit
hey why'd that green falcon fall out of
falcon formation black falcon get on
that report back
black falcon
black falcon come in
[Music]
got to be careful here
this place is crawling with them
what was that what
cover me
guys hey guys
hey guys
oh thank god and we started a community
as survivors
y'all come live with us
wait how did you know
come on
redneck wants us to move into his
community
us
let's go
would you let me date your daughter of
course
[Music]
oh my god oh my god oh my god
please don't hurt me uh
my best friend's black and i love jay-z
and uh my favorite movie is think like a
man
she's good come with us
stay close okay what's your name emily
of course it is
what do you think about the police
i love the third album
i i i don't have any money
no money
oh my god oh my god thank god you guys
showed up i gotta get out of here
it's a silver lexus just pull it right
up front and don't scuff the paint all
right i just had it buffed
was he an alien too yep
[Music]
oh damn
check that it out
what
is
that
i didn't know they made them like that
i don't even understand what i'm seeing
i would love to see what's under there i
am really curious about that
yeah
i mean i have no idea
well you know we uh we obviously have
some idea you know
[Laughter]
i don't
well you know it's uh you know it's a
coochie baby
yeah or something
ah nah nah nah man it's it's it's
definitely her lady parts
or
maybe it's just more skin
no
it's a vagina yeah
or
maybe it's a little face under there
uh no no it's it's definitely gonna be a
vagina
why but because she's a girl and girls
have vaginas man
what is that
what is a vagina
it's a woman's reproductive organ what
are you being serious right now
[Music]
thank you
that is all i require
there's aliens
there's an alien down here
the zombies have broken through i repeat
zombies
oh my god
tommy's been bad
forgive me
i can't believe the zombie's been up
zombies are raccoons right
[Music]
no it's just zombies
oh
you just killed tommy
[Music]